being an actor on The Walking Dead was a
tough gig and not just because you could
be killed off at any time
the season 7 premiere of The Walking
Dead is arguably its most notorious
episode it's the one where Negan leader
of the saviors bashes Glenn and
Abraham's brains out with his barbed
wire wrapped baseball bat Lucille he
commits this act of savagery in an
effort to break the spirits of the
victim's loved ones who are forced to
kneel and watch it or happen it's an
unrelentingly Bleak hour that's an
endurance test for even the show's
biggest fans but as hard as it is to
watch it was even harder to film oh look
at that taking it like a champ the
actors spent a total of six nights
kneeling on the ground in the woods two
nights for the season six finale and
four more for the season 7 premiere in
an interview with GQ Steven Yoon who
played Glenn recalled shooting the
emotionally draining episode saying just
on your knees on the gravel pretending
and believing that you're about to die
it was gnarly but even though it was
yoon's character whose eyeball popped
out of his skull he said Andrew Lincoln
made the biggest sacrifice because we
saw the events unfolds Through The Eyes
of brick Grimes not only that much of
the episode is just him and Negan as
Yoon said you're asking Andrew Lincoln
to basically spend 10 days in a hole of
Despair and he did it which one of you
Pricks is the leader
is this one
he's the guy it was physically and
emotionally painful for the rest of the
cast too Lauren Cohan who played Glenn's
wife Maggie said filming Glenn's death
was the hardest scene she's ever had to
do as an actor
Negan is the ultimate antagonist of The
Walking Dead and Jeffrey Dean Morgan
proved to be more than up to the task
but that doesn't mean his job was easy
when I sent my people to kill your
people for killing my people
you killed more of my people embodying
negan's cruelty took a toll on him to
the point where he seriously considered
quitting whether they were playing the
good guy or the villain their brutal
power struggle was equally emotionally
draining for both Morgan and Andrew
Lincoln fortunately for fans who
persevered and although the result is
difficult to watch the quality of both
actors work is undeniable Morgan shared
that he found a way to make Peter's
playing a vile character like Negan by
attempting to empathize with him even
going so far as to find him somewhat
endearing and it clearly worked because
Morgan is opted to sacrifice his mental
Tranquility at least one more time he
returns his knee gun in the spin-off
series The Walking Dead dead City
The Walking Dead is filmed outside in
the summer in Georgia at the height of
Summer it's muggy 90 of the time in
sanoya a Show's base of operations it's
the kind of humidity that stops your
energy even if you're wearing shorts and
a t-shirt and performers on The Walking
Dead are wearing heavy cargo pants
flannels leather and prosthetic maker
Steven noon blacked out during his first
day on set because he had to do several
takes sprinting on an empty stomach I
remember just dripping with sweat and
everybody seeing the rushes apparently
and it just looked like we were in a
shower Novak does had it worse than
those who played the skin suit wearing
Whisperers they had to wear what were
basically rubber ski masks for long
periods of time Samantha Morton who
played whisper Elita Alpha said that the
heat made her forget her lines telling
Insider when you're in The Mask your
head gets so hot and it's really hard
for your concentration you kind of get a
bit of brain fog because you get hot
Ryan Hurst who played Alphas hulking
second in command Beta had a costume
pretty much designed to make him pass
out I am at your service frownie mc2
knives he wore a whisper a mask his own
big beard a leather trench coat and two
more layers under there and he kept the
mask on between take sustained character
and surprisingly he had to be
hospitalized for heat exhaustion at one
point
every time there's a new enemy on The
Walking Dead it captured Daryl Dixon but
the worst was the time saviors tried to
recruit him to their cause by holding
him in a jail cell and torturing him
Carol
yeah
you deserve a happy ending too first of
all Norman Reedus was naked while he
filmed it the saviors are trying to
humiliate him and reader shows her
sacrifice his own dignity for
authenticity's sake in an interview with
TV Guide he said I walked in and
wardrobe was like do you want to wear a
Sarco via junk and I was like nope it's
kind of like watching a tennis match I
sat down naked in front of the whole
camera crew and everyone's head just
moved to the right and it was like they
were watching Wimbledon redis doesn't
only sacrifice his dignity he sacrifices
his body too he once gave himself a
black eye with his own crossbow in
season five he cut his arm open while
filming a scene in a barn readers told
the rap they said they actually saw my
arm opening up and Blood start coming
out of my arm on camera during a season
6 scene he cut his finger on broken
glass while reaching into a vending
machine which prompted him to wonder to
Entertainment Weekly why am I always
getting hurt I get hurt all the time I
feel like I should have like football
pads on at all times even when I'm just
walking around finally while filming
season 11 undercovered protocols he got
stiff armed by a zombie performer was
trying to keep a surgical mask out of
the shot but readers rolled with it
selling Express I finally got manhandled
by the zombie
AMC Studio bosses were so impressed with
the source material of The Walking Dead
that they ordered the whole series up
front they estimated that it would take
12 Seasons to finish the entire Arc
Andrew Lincoln who was newly married
with a young family and patiently
waiting for his big break had to make
the decision to uproot their lives
potentially indefinitely to a foreign
country but passing up the once in a
lifetime opportunity was Unthinkable so
he made the sacrifice of relocating his
young family to Atlanta Georgia where
the majority of the show was eventually
shut when his children Grew Older and
returned to London Lincoln chose to
leave the show after nine Seasons to
spend more time with them
tonight Guerrero played Michonne in The
Walking Dead a character who was
consistently Illustrated with her Katana
in the comics Michonne joined the core
cast in season three and was a series
Mainstay from that point on but when she
showed up to work she learned the
physical training was more extensive
than she'd originally thought Guerrera
had martial arts training as part of her
MFA programmer NYU nevertheless she
admits that training for The Walking
Dead was a different ball game it wasn't
only about getting in shape but also
about learning how to wield the katana
it takes a lot of effort to wield a
sword all day long she told the Chicago
Tribune you do your little dumbbells and
you're getting somewhere but the katana
just totally will break you and I love
it for that but it was a lot of work
while filming the show she had a real
Katana a wooden one and a plastic one to
facilitate her training at home Guerrero
is known to fully immerse herself in her
roles even shaving her head for black
panther she felt that since the katana
was so important to Michonne knowing how
to handle it gave her away into her
character and her commitment and
dedication to the roles certainly paid
off
Lauren cohan's fight for a pay Paris he
became the talk of Hollywood when she
made it clear to her bosses at AMC that
she was prepared to sacrifice her role
on The Walking Dead if her salary wasn't
increased Kohan joined season two of The
Walking Dead as Maggie a member of the
green Clan known for their strict
adherence to Christianity the family
owned the Ranch at the main cast used
for Refuge over six seasons Maggie Green
transformed from a naive country girl to
one of the most formidable leaders
within the main group the future is ours
The World Is Ours Terry Han's popularity
among fans increased the development of
her character Anika praised her standout
performance then her contract came up
for Renewal with her growing importance
to the show Kohan believed her
compensation should align more closely
with that of a male co-lead a view not
shared by AMC Executives Kohan stuck to
her guns and left the series happily for
fans Cohan managed to find her way back
to The Walking Dead for its final season
and hopefully her willingness to walk
away from one of the most popular shows
on television made a positive impact
particularly considering the multiple
spin-offs have emerged from The Walking
Dead
Josh McDermott's character Eugene Porto
is arguably the most grating member of
the main group on The Walking Dead it's
enjoyable as hell the thing about an
undead ankle a sore going after a
diplodocus
that there's a video game worth of
pre-order Eugene initially joins a gang
with a lie claiming to know the cure for
the Walker infestation he's soon exposed
as just another grifter but gradually
builds rapport with the group and proves
himself to be useful one way the
creators made Eugene instantly unlikable
was through his abysmal fashion sense
Eugene is always seen wearing hiking
boots cargo shorts and committing
perhaps the most Cardinal Fashion Center
of all rocking a mullet in the 21st
century it's Hollywood so fans didn't
expect the mullet to be real but
McDermott actually sacrificed his vanity
for Eugene signature style he hated it
but as a stand-up comedian he found a
way to maintain his sense of humor about
the whole situation McDermott confessed
that later on he actually enjoyed
looking ridiculous on TV
a lot of mastersons to Elder brothers
were on That 70s Show and Malcolm in the
Middle so she grew up in and around the
industry but although she may have
gotten a start at an actor because of
her connections she quickly proved
herself as a consummate professional as
Tara Chambler on The Walking Dead Master
son was so dedicated that she powered
through 18-hour days even while she was
pregnant The Walking Dead cast never
failed to mention just how close knit
they are as a group Master son
experience sets on her very first day it
was her 25th birthday but to her
disappointment she didn't have any
scenes with the main cast instead she
found herself on the side of the
governor this worried her because she
thought fans might not like her
character due to her association with
the villain but she was immediately
consoled by Stephen Yoon and Andrew
Lincoln who went out of their way to
welcome her to the cast it was a warm
Cast Connection that inspired her to
push through the long grueling days she
believed that if nobody else was
complaining she shouldn't either and if
that doesn't qualify as a sacrifice made
for the show then we don't know what
does
Michael Rook his card to Mel Dixon
undergoes one of the most satisfying
Redemption acts in The Walking Dead
however as is often the case in the
world of the Walkers no good deed goes
unpunished he eventually gets turned
into a walker by the governor and his
brother has to kill him when asked in an
interview with TV Guide about his
reaction to the news that his character
would be killed off Rooker replied I
found out about two weeks before the
episode I was actually quite relieved
because I wouldn't have to wear the arm
again honestly that was my first thought
thank you thank you I don't have to put
that goddamn thing on ever again but
then I realized oh sh amount of a job
the prosthetic handy war on the show
cause real nerve damage
a hard time but despite the obvious pain
Rooker has never been one to complain
too much he later mentioned that
although it wasn't the most pleasant
experience he still loves the prosthetic
hand Rooker even went so far as to say
that the two-hour makeup sessions you
had to endure for his walker scenes
weren't all that difficult considering
get experienced much longer sessions for
movies like slither